vous êtes là là où ça bouge spécial
théâtre ce soir nous sommes à saint
siméon dans l'orne pour un poème rock
qui s'appelle la bataille des scandales
on vous en reparle dans quelques
instants
mais je vous propose d'aller retrouver
samy daniel et carole lefrançois au
théâtre d'hérouville avec deux géants de
cette discipline de cet art qu'est le
théâtre
depuis trop longtemps a dit à mon frère
les attentions sont excellentes
si l'âge ça calvé j'en suis très
contente des choses seront plus simples
le trait mathilde de rentrer d'algérie à
cause des événements mais adrien son
frère lui dispute son héritage
l'action se passe dans une ville de
province ou dans les années 60 des
ratonnades donner la mesure de
l'hospitalité ambiante retour au désert
de koltès est une satire de la
bourgeoisie et de la famille mais pas
que bien dans cette comédie c'est
grinçante grinçante inquiétant dit notre
mettant en scène il a raison d'ailleurs
parce que effectivement forme
d'inquiétude nourrissent notre metteur
en scène arnaud meunier qui se baladent
dans la pièce et y croise à la fois des
thèmes politiques et puis des histoires
de famille un peu sordide qu'il traite
de manière à la fois grinçante émouvante
et drôle
voilà est ce que mathilde eux c'est une
femme qui en impose qu'yves s'impose
comment vous avez envie vous de la
difficile à définir
c'est un personnage très fort et très
fragile c'est un personnage finalement
qui ne peut pas payer qui est déraciné
qui a dû quitter metz à la fin de la
guerre sur dénonciation mensongère et
qui s'était tondre comme on l'a fait le
salaire beaucoup de femmes très belle
période française ou si sa très jolie et
donc être dû fuir comme ça qui a fait
deux enfants ou sans les pères donc si
nous avons assez libre moderne donc à la
cette forme là en même temps elle ne
peut pas vivre sans son frère
et ça c'est ce qui la rend belle grande
touchante
demain
se passe quelque chose que peu étrange
dans cette maison et je le déteste
n'est ce pas là bas je me cache là
je dis souvent quand on me pose des
questions sur la pièce que c'est un
croisement entre chabrol shakespeare
mais il ya quelque chose de ça c'est
qu'il ya des histoires familiales panne
est bon voilà et puis il ya les lans
littéraire de koltès qui venait
d'ailleurs de traduire shakespeare avant
d'écrire la pièce et qui tout d'un coup
découvrent la liberté élisabéthaine
shakespearienne des raccords dans une
minute
oui voyez là on va vous laisser sur
cette parole de fin merci nous avoir
reçus dans quelques minutes qui seront
sur scène ici à la comédie de caen pour
retour des verts de bernard-marie koltès
mise en scène par arnaud meunier merci
merci merci à vous voilà une femme
criblé de dettes
nous allons vous raconter son histoire
c'est l'histoire d'une dame
c'est l'histoire d'une femme qui se
retrouve dans une situation de grande
précarité économique est sur le point de
se faire expulser de chez elles par les
huissiers parce que la plume ne peut
plus payer ses sont sans logement depuis
plusieurs mois est donc dans une
situation d'impasse et elle se met à
imaginer qu'un séisme ravage la ville où
elle vit qui a une soeur de grandes
catastrophes qui pourraient la libérer
de cette situation d'impasse personnel
il reste droit en vitrine est lente et
sel reste noir se regarde dans la glace
qu'est ce que tu en penses musique l on
dirait une madame 2 une vraie
pense-t-elle
qui ne baisseraient pas les yeux c'est
votre mission le théâtre du préau
d'aller justement vers là où il n'y a
pas forcément de théâtre ici c'est une
commune 280 habitants
il ya pourtant une jolie salle il ya
pourtant une très jolie salle et puis il
ya aussi des gens qui ont vraiment ce
désir de travailler avec nous et ça
pourrait pas se faire sans ses relais
mais fier en même temps dans une petite
commune comme saint siméon d'avoir le
théâtre du préau pour un poème rock qui
plus est puisque c'est quand même est
une création et ils repartent ensemble
direction l'école de michael pour
commencer la vie nouvelle
zaza fournier en concert demain soir à
saint martin de bréhal puis ensuite à
querqueville demain soir dans là où ça
bouge
inna modja alençon et dominique ardres à
hérouville au bbc
à demain
je